and out of the person who will present
our first award I have very few lines on
Miss Patricia Neal however she has quite
a few of her own to present the special
effects award miss Patricia Neal
you
the job of the special effects
Department is to stage impossible
happenings on the screen there are two
excellent examples of such miracles this
current year in mightyjoyoung
they are responsible for converting a
pile of lumber a roll of tar paper and a
stack of old who pays into an 80-foot
gorilla you'd swear was alive and
breathing in the picture Tulsa the
special effects people came up with a
blistering oil field fire so realistic
that it singed eyebrows in the balcony
the real miracle of that job is that on
the screen the fog that is an area of 13
thousand acres and yet this spectacle
was staged on a table no larger than the
one you have in your dining room those
are the two accomplishments nominated
here tonight mighty Joe Young and our Co
production RKO radio Tulsa
Walter Ranger picture eagle lion Mr
Francis Holford of Price Waterhouse the
Antelope if you please the winner is
Mikey Joe Young our co-production
and now the first winner of the 22nd
annual award is approaching this
very dutifully decorated stage
and if mr. Willis H O'Brien who created
the great
thank you very very much
thank you miss Patricia kneeling
congratulations mr. Willis H O'Brian